[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello there
[Music]
hey
before any speech I ever make I always
acknowledge my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ because he said if you don't
acknowledge him he's not going to
acknowledge you and I also want to
acknowledge my wife Julie because she's
in this fight with me
and I saw also want to acknowledge all
of you and thank you for being here
because uh together we're gonna win this
thing and I say together
because you know I'm running against a
guy that doesn't know anything about
togetherness
he seemed to know about separation
but I want him to know that in the great
book that I read
it says A House Divided cannot stand
and so I'm not going to let him divide
my house and all of you are part of my
house because I said God is a good god
is he not
and uh the other day I heard him say
that uh to be a senator you have to know
some stuff
so I wanted to tell him some stuff he
didn't know
because in that debate y'all saw he
didn't know a lot of stuff
and he decided at one time to become
Scooby-Doo y'all saw that so they asked
him if he would vote for Biden in 2024
and he said oh oh no and I was like yeah
but he don't know that at this time
right now
God prepared me for this moment
and I'm gonna explain to you guys what
happened because I thought I was his
football player
but no no no no no God has something
else in plan for me
because I grew up in that little town
y'all heard of it Riceville Georgia
and I tell everyone if you got one year
to live move to Wrightsville that years
forever same old same old
and I also grew up with a speech
impediment
so for four years of my life I never
went out for a recess
four years of my life I never took a
never spoke in a classroom
my mom said I was big boned to make me
feel good because I was fat
so I didn't feel good about myself
but God had a plan
and that plan he had let's get me to the
University of Georgia and Georgia is in
the SEC Championship game are they not
no one is in the SEC Championship game
so he got me a chance to go to the
University of Georgia
and then he got me a chance to win a
Heisman Trophy think about this now
that's from this kid and y'all probably
realize that I'm black I didn't know I
was black until I got up here today but
I'm blind
and I got a chance to go to the 1992
Olympic bob sled to represent the United
States of America and there's absolutely
no snow here in Georgia think about it I
got a chance to be on that team
and I got a chance to build this was so
funny I got a chance to build so many
different things that God has done for
me but this is what was so funny he said
I wasn't ready yet guys so you're not
ready yet
and I didn't know what he was doing to
me and then all of a sudden uh somebody
said I had a mental problem think about
this now this is a young man never drink
before in my life guys I never tasted
beer never had any alcohol never taken a
drug never had any medicine in this body
and they said yeah that was a good thing
but then all of a sudden they said I had
a mental problem like wait a minute I
had to work at Herschel Walker have a
mental problem I'm talking about myself
in third person but I know that
so I decided to go to this Hospital out
in California
so I went to this Hospital out in
California I go whoa these people here
are crazy
and they're crazy I'm not like them
and then from my upbringing but my mom
and dad taught me
from my Lord Jesus that we all fall
short of the glory of God
that we start working on ourselves and
stop looking at the plaint uh the dust
in my brother's eye but look at the
plank in my own so I got washed in the
blood of Jesus at that time and my life
blossomed and God said you're ready now
and so all of a sudden I started
watching television
and I'm telling you don't be watching TV
because they were totally confusion
because I started watching a man on TV
and I heard him say
America need a apologize for it
whiteness
in American either apologize for the
whiteness and I said wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait they buy
the Bible I read
God doesn't know anything about the
color of your skin
God knows about your heart
that's what he knows about your heart
and then he said you know you can't
serve the military and God at the same
time
and then he called all men and women in
blue and I said wait a minute wait a
minute wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
what are we doing here
what are we doing here
and so I said wait wait wait it is time
for us to get men in Washington that's
going to do right by the people that
elected them to go to office that love
the United States of America that love
the Constitution you got to get people
that's not afraid to speak the truth not
go to Washington to do whatever somebody
tells you to do because I'm gonna tell
you God don't want no politician because
y'all know I'm not a politician y'all
y'all seen politicians like that look
like this right here y'all never seen
father look like that
he don't want that but God wanted his
Warriors that's going to go up there and
tell people the right truth because my
father told me no he meant no
and then I got too big for my britches
he said boy if you don't like the rules
underneath my roof you leave my house
so we need to get people in Washington
said if you don't like the rules of the
United States of America you can leave
we're not we're not asking you to stay
but no no no but let me go to this right
here so all of a sudden this man that
said to be a senator you have to know
stuff
I'm trying to figure out what the he
know well first of all he voted four
times to get rid of the Keystone
Pipeline does he not know the definition
of enemy because they go into our enemy
they ask for energy to help us
and the enemy of people that don't like
you I don't know if y'all know that
those are people that don't like you but
they also didn't know the definition of
a woman and he is a minister man out of
cloth and if he had looked it up in that
great book that I read it said a man and
a woman he should have known the
definition of a woman but he didn't know
that but he tried to fool you also by
telling you that a man can get pregnant
no he can't get pregnant he can't get
pregnant so they're trying to lie to you
so I'm gonna tell you about these lies
and this is the reason I decided to run
because I'm gonna tell you this little
story I've been telling for a long time
it's about this guy that died early in
life
he died early in life and as he got to
Heaven Saint Peter met him at the Pearly
Gates
and Saint Peter said sir you're here a
little bit early right now
that your name ain't on the road
so you're the only one in history
they're going to get an opportunity to
decide where you want to go
he said I'm gonna take you to heaven and
I'm gonna take you to hell and you get
to determine where you like to be
so he puts him in his elevator he takes
him all the way down the hill and the
doors open up
and there's a party going on
he see some of his friends dying he's
having a great time
and after a couple of hours Saint Peter
came to him and said uh you ready to go
you're ready to go and the guy said we
got to leave and I said yes you got a
decision to make so he puts him in his
elevator takes him all the way up to
heaven
they get to heaven and there are people
floating around on clouds
having a good time
and after a couple of hours say Peter
came to him and said have you made your
mind up
you made your mind up and the guy said
well Saint Pete
I hate to tell you this but I think I
want to go to hell
that doesn't seem like my type of place
Saint Peter said are you sure you say
yes he puts him in his elevator sends
them all the way back down the hill the
doors open up nice hot
people are crying and they're miserable
and the guy said wait a minute wait a
minute a couple of hours ago when I was
here there was a party going on
Satan shows up and said a couple hours
ago I was campaigning
well the reason I'm telling you that
right now the guy I'm running against
the campaign and he's lying to you and
he's a man out of cough and he's lying
to you telling you that this is a new
normal he's lying to you telling you
that everything is okay but no it's not
he's the reason that crime is the way it
is because he called all men and women
and blue Thugs and bullets
Nana morale is down recruitment is down
this is the worst time in America to be
a lawyer enforcement officer because
people have forgotten about their people
too
they've forgotten about right now they
have families their moms and dads their
brothers and sisters but yet we got
people in Washington that call them
names they got the morale down they can
continue to vote for judges that don't
believe in no cash bail
and I'm like man the good book that I
read the Bible even said with Adam and
Eve you have this place here that say
you have total freedom but if you touch
and eat for this tree here you'll surely
die they were held to responsibility but
we got people in Washington that don't
want to hold people responsible for what
they're doing
that's the guy I'm running against
him running against do not even want to
apologize because he even said and it's
on the pulpit talking about me on this
Pulpit he said it because I'm talking
about him I'm talking about Jesus that
I'm talking about him I'm talking about
Martin Luther King but he need to know
because he don't know stuff he need to
know he's not Jesus and he not Dr King
that's what he needed to learn he's
neither one of those people because of
either those people he wouldn't be doing
the things till he's doing to those
people at this apartment unit y'all seen
the Columbia Towers that's a place 99 of
the church owned that place but yet he's
evicting people for 29 that's what he's
evicting for him and he's making seventy
four hundred dollars a month for his
housing allowance but yet he continued
to spend your money and think about this
in less than two years think about what
he's done to this country
people gonna ask me why I'm running I'm
running because I got a wolf in sheep
clothing on the pulpit trying to tell
you that you're evil people but it's not
going to do it on my watch not on my
watch because we're good people here
we're good people here and the way we
can become better is we gotta come
together where we can come better we got
to get together get people like that out
of office because I'm sick and tired of
people sitting and watching that lives
in the greatest country in the world
today and all they do is complain and
complain we don't want to hear
complaints we want to hear Solutions
that's what I want to do I want to be a
guy that got to do solution and the way
I'm getting to the solutions done for
you because I told you by the Keystone
Pipeline that he voted four times to get
rid of what I want to do is we start
drilling for our own oil and gas on our
own here right here in the United States
of America because we can do it
environmentally friendly do you all not
know that we can do it very well just as
good as anyone and then when they get to
the point that we get to we want to get
to the green new deal I will raise my
hand but we're not at that point yeah
we're not there yet so why they're
trying to force into something they do
we're not ready to go yet we need to get
to what we're doing because they're
becoming a national security problem
thinking about it they're going to our
enemies they're going to terrorists
they're going to dictators asking them
to help us we don't need them to help us
we can help ourselves we need to get rid
of the government and get back to the
people this is about we the people not
we the government man and then no no no
no no no no let me let me say this this
is less than two short years you need to
know stuff he don't know what he said
about our men and women in the military
that they are they can't serve God in
the military at the same time he's not
God so he don't need to be telling
things like that first of all you can
serve God in the military God is a good
god and our military was the most lethal
fighting force ever assembler was our
United States military but because of
people like him and Washington not every
coming week because they're talking
about pronouns
bsar's pronouns like what the heck is a
pronoun are y'all not sick and tired of
this pronoun stuff I know I'm sick and
tired of this pronoun stuff and then no
no no no no no no what we're gonna do is
call him a pronoun he's going to be
former Senator Pro now that's his name
former Senator pronoun because you know
what we don't need to talk with pronouns
for our military why don't we talk about
push-ups and sit-ups I've been doing a
lot of those let's talk about that let's
get out of this pronoun stuff and then
not only that this is what the guy is
doing to us this is a guy that wants you
to vote for him I'm trying to tell you
to vote for him because we need to know
stuff what he need to know is get it out
of our school too they're bringing this
wokeness in our school house after our
little kids because they know we're a
little bit too old We're not gonna fall
for them taking us down in that elevator
so they're trying to take our little
kids down there they're trying to tell
them because you're white you're in a
your uh oppressor and because you're
black you're the oppressed you can't get
in you can't do anything well no it's
not but if you live in the United States
of America you can have that American
Dream but you got to get people in
Washington that's going to give you that
American dream and give you an
opportunity not because of the color of
your skin that's what he needed to get
back to give people the opportunity to
do it and the way you do it is by
believing in the people believing in
everybody and I believe in everybody and
I'm gonna tell people this and I'll tell
you this with my offensive lineman told
me one day there's a Hershey you follow
me I'm gonna take you to the promised
land
so I tell all you you vote for me imma
help us all get to the promised land
because I believe that we can't get
there if we don't get that together none
of us get there at all because I'm not
gonna say I'm taking part of my family
because I'm gonna tell you something you
may not know about me I got white people
in my family can you believe that
I even got black people in my family I
know you can't believe that I'm kidding
I got Asian I got all types of people in
my family you know what we're all mutts
but I love every last one of them and
let me tell you something else you may
be a mutt too because 23andMe screwed us
all up so they don't matter about what
you are what it does matter is you're an
American it does not matter that's good
enough We're All American so we need to
start fighting for American to quit
fighting about color it don't matter
about the color of your skin we are
American and do we not and you know what
we're very generous we're very generous
but what we got to do is get back into
our Schoolhouse and get that CRT out of
our school critical race there at our
school what we need to do is teach our
kids how to read and write rather than
teaching them right critical race Theory
need to teach them how to spell rather
than teaching them about gender ideology
and then we need to get some people in
there to protect our kids while they're
in the schoolhouse instead of having 87
000 RS agents that's going to go after
you 87 a thousand rshas what do y'all
think they're gonna do
they're going after us and they know
that but yet they don't want to do that
but we need people with common sense and
watching that's what I have I have
common sense so I do know a lot of stuff
I know a whole lot of stuff and what I
do know is we don't need 87 000 RS agent
I do know that and I do know this as
well we do need to secure the Border
y'all know we need a security border hey
yes we do and they say this board is
secured can y'all believe that these
people have lost their freaking mind
this board are not secured what it is
you got people coming across this border
you don't see people coming across the
border China do you you don't see people
coming across the board of Russia do you
because they don't want to be in Russia
they don't want to be in China they want
to be in the United States of America
because this is the greatest country in
the world today even at we at the point
we're at right now so what we got to do
is protect this country and the way we
protected it by coming together you
can't be separated protecting me early
on I said a house the body cannot stay
in but that's what the left is trying to
do they're trying to divide you with
these lies take you down to that
elevator and fool you tell you this is a
new normal this is not the new normal
but what you need is a champion in
Washington and that's what God Said
Hersch is that champion that I've got he
built me up for a time like this do
y'all think I wanted to be a politician
guys I don't even wear suits only we
don't put on a suit test that I can show
them I can wear my neck is too big to be
wearing a tie I'm not wearing a tie they
know that but this is what I'm running
against I'm running against this slick
preacher this slick preacher that talks
so smooth y'all saw what he was saying
in that debate trying to think he can
out talk hers for Walker do y'all really
believe this man can beat me at a debate
he had to have something going wrong
with him he don't know from the school
to Rick and Bobby
yes you I am I'm from that school to
Ricky Bobby and I'm always going to
finish first because he's a one-trick
pony he thought he could say things and
fool me have y'all heard him talk about
how he would think it's okay to kill a
baby all the way up to nine months he's
saying it's okay to kill a baby he even
said if a baby survived an abortion he
would deny that baby Medical Care and he
is a man out of cloth let's think about
who we got representing Us in Washington
it is time for him to go he needed no
stuff where he don't know it's time for
him to go and what we're going to tell
and don't let that door hit you in the
bite side if you walk out of the people
office we need leaders in Washington
going to do the right thing by the
people you're the people so you've got
the voices though that's why you gotta
vote that's why I'ma tell y'all get out
and vote get out of the vote until 10 of
your friends get out and vote if you
don't have any friends make some friends
and tell them to get out and vote this
is one of the most important elections
we're going to have in our lifetime so
what we got to do we got to get out and
correct this right now because we got
people in watch that become weak have
they talked about those 10 people that
was killed in Afghanistan
they talked about people that were
killed in Afghanistan that's a show that
we were weak you think leaders around
Washington around this world not looking
at us looking at us telling us that
we're weak but I'm telling you right now
America don't have weak people we have
strong people we have people that have
come so far and think about this they're
trying to take you back they're trying
to take you down in that elevator and
tell you that this is a new normal it is
not the new normal it is not the new
normal and let me tell you about this
green New Deal
his green New Deal it is not as it's
exciting it isn't it they're talking
about all this green New Deal stuff is
very exciting and I'm gonna tell you
right now I told you early on when they
get to the point that we can get to this
green new deal I will raise my hand
we're not there yet because I was
talking to some Farmers the other day
this is what was so funny about these
Farmers y'all know if this is a big
Agriculture state y'all know that don't
you we do all this for them and all this
agriculture I'm one of these country
boys so all of a sudden I asked somebody
what will the combine cost today y'all
know what they told me they said a used
combine cost five hundred thousand
dollars and I go whoa that's a lot of
money and I said where would the
electric combine cost
they said about 1.8 million dollars out
of the world that's a whole lot of money
right there but this is what was so
funny about it they said you can only
use it for two hours then you have to
charge it so it won't work and I'm like
guys so it won't work so while we're
here talking about it why don't we get
by he's not working but he's doing okay
he's doing okay he's doing the best he
can that's reason he got to go the best
you can don't work they need to put the
a team in the B team had enough time to
be in there not a time for The A Team to
go in and play and that's why I said put
me in the game coach I'm ready to play
I've been ready to play since I started
out and I'm ready to get in the game and
change this attitude we got people
watching that not doing the right thing
and it is time that we change it but the
way we change it by getting out to vote
so we don't just show up we gotta do
what the right for the people and as I
said God loves us he loves us all but
this is our problem we have people we
have people in Washington have forgotten
about this flag the United States flag
and then they continue to have people
that want to debate whether you're going
to kneel or you're going to see it but
that won't happen on my watch because
too many people have sacrificed their
lives they've sacrificed everything for
this flag for this Anthem and what you
got to do is respect it all and once you
start disrespecting that's when the
problems happen and that's what we let
them get away with let them disrespect
the flag and I said no no no it won't
happen on my watch no more you retiring
to get back to what is right this is a
country of immigrants but we also a
country of laws that's the reason that
we would got to where we at today now
they want to change us they want to
change they want to take us back because
I remember Archer Barker
yeah I remember Archer Barker y'all
remember Arch Market too and now Archie
Parker couldn't be on the air today
because now people too sensitive let me
tell you what sensitivity has nothing to
do with what's happening in this country
right now crime is up crime is up
because we got a week when the senator
like Senator why not want to call all
men Thugs and bullets crimes are up
because we got people like that want to
release people from jail where it's not
going to happen on my wife so I want to
tell you all this what we got to do get
your friends and go out and vote tell
everyone to go out and vote it is time
we get this right and the way we get it
right by putting me in the Senate
because I'm not gonna dance and sing for
nobody I never have and never will
because I represent the great people of
Georgia I've lived here my whole life I
owe so much to the great people of
Georgia to the state of Georgia do you
all think I'm gonna let you down I
scored one time and I can score again I
can promise you that I won one
Championship I win again I don't want to
win trophies I want to win national
championships that's what I like
National Championship that's what George
is going to win this coming year a
national championship they're going to
win a championship that's what I want us
to be national champions we can't do it
with Senator Warner in the office this
vampire thing is good if they play the
whole thing they would have known the
vampire thing had to do with uh having
uh Faith they didn't want to play the
whole thing they're lying to you taking
you down this elevator and I'm gonna
tell you right now don't let them take
in this elevator but what we gotta do
come together
come together as one
God is a good God God bless you God
thank you guys now
[Music]
[Music]